jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen zu
meinem heutigen video
ich habe mir überlegt dass auf youtube
irgendwie oftmals der gleiche content
ist beziehungsweise dass einzelne
personen oft ähnliches zeug machen
deshalb habe ich mir überlegt dass sie
eine challenge ins leben rufe erstes mal
challenge heißt das ganze und das
funktioniert so youtuber die dazu
nominiert werden sind aufgefordert
sieben dinge in einem video zu tun die
sie davor noch niemals gemacht haben
wenn ihr wollt dass daraus so ein ding
wird dann lasst die leute wissen die
später nominiere dass sie es unbedingt
machen sollen okay wir schauen mal auf
meine schlauer liste was habe ich mir so
aufgeschrieben was ich noch nie gemacht
habe
nummer eins ballett tanzen disposition 1
2 3 und 4 1 geworfen
ballett viel komplizierter als es
aussieht aber das ja auch in diesem sinn
von weihnachten vielleicht aussieht
facto zur nächsten sache sachen nummer
zwei hohe schuhe tragen und damit rum
laufen die nicht mal meine größe haben
okay leute mit hohen schuhen laufen
oh gott das sind wie viele zentimeter 11
zentimeter oder lvmh zentimeter ich habe
absolut keine ahnung wo frauen wie
können wir es schaffen
richtig graziös aber hier ist noch
kassetten wird wenn man normale viel so
anders so wir noch weiter oben ist 12 3
lauf hier raus bin froh dass ich so was
nicht trage meine füße tun jetzt richtig
weh die gelenke
aber egal heißt es auch mal gemacht
nummer drei in einem video singen
trinken
den song
syncos mes betroffen
tst
die weltnummer 4 meine haarfarbe ändern
also ich nicht permanent fernen aber ich
werde mit seiner haar kreide meine
haarfarbe ändern und ich bin sehr
gespannt wie es aussieht das jahr über
voll cool und will die für immer so
behalten ihr seht schon location wechsel
wir sind jetzt im bad und ich werde mir
die haare zumindest vorübergehend mit
kreide was wir für verpflichtungen to
play so viel farbe grau in grau
man kann erstmal baisweil machen und
dank leute so sieht das aus wie zu mir
weißt aber ich weiß nicht ich denke aber
wir haben das trocknen lässt dann wird
es noch weiter
also leute so sieht das ganze final aus
man sieht dass es keine echte farbe ist
glaube es ist es halt noch nicht
komplett getrocknet aber man sieht schon
definitiv das ist das was für ein grau
sein soll voll ungewohnt hat in meinem
leben noch nie eine andere haarfarbe als
meine eigene auf dem kopf ok mit diesem
blauen strich daher besonders sich ein
bisschen aus wie ein power ranger weiß
aber nicht ob ich mir meine haare
permanent färben was heißt permanent
also es geht ja früher oder später weg
klar aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das
machen würde
ein ernsthaftes musici machen ihr wisst
ja ich hab den musik lied trend so ein
bisschen kritisch verfolgt und ich werde
jetzt einfach diese challenge dazu
nutzen einen ernst gemeint ist musical
zu machen bestimmt kann ich es überhaupt
mit kay relativ schwierig und musical zu
machen
aber so eine minimale choreografie steht
wir probieren es mal auf gehören ist
sollte zum glück habe ich meine freundin
music die expertin ist ferling der
beschreibung 2 aber schon bei janko baum
und dann nochmal hoch oder beim
sendlinger der norm iso aufhören
okay leute nach einer gefühlten stunde
war das musical fertig aber die app hat
einfach irgendwie die synchronisation
verhauen und es ist komplett
durcheinander obwohl ewigkeiten daran
waren jetzt gerade große satan musici
ich guck mal ob ich das irgendwie ein
bisschen retten kann ihr seht jetzt das
produkt das hat aber eigentlich spaß
gemacht
106 eine beauty maske auftragen habe ich
an ordentlich gemacht los geht's mit der
maske kommt zum allerersten mal in
meinem leben eine beauty maske leute was
zur hölle tue ich hier
ok also es fühlt sich zwar gut an aber
ist sie einfach so sagte mir jemand mit
dünnschiss ins gesicht gesagt ich lasse
es jetzt erstmal trocknen und dann sage
ich euch mein fazit dazu leute in der
zwischenzeit ist die kamera gegangen und
nicht nur das sondern dieses zeug
beginnt zu trocknen und ich sehe einfach
aus es könnte nämlich bei kanye west
schießen zu kaufen
es ist voll verrückt aber irgendwie
fühlt sich richtig gut an
macht das auch immer so die maske ist
jetzt noch nicht ganz aber für mich ganz
genug bradley smith sache oder
eindrücklich
es ist lustig und macht es jetzt ab also
die maske ist wieder ab das fühlt sich
gut an
ich habe so ein bisschen was politiker
heilerde auf den zähnen ganz bisschen
aber das echt cool also es führt sie
extrem nice an die haut nachdem man das
drauf hatte und eigentlich keine mal ist
echt öfters mal machen also gut für
ausprobiert habe und zuletzt nummer 7
einfach mal menschen die ich gerne habe
sagen dass ich sie gern habe so außer
kontext nicht irgendwie im gespräch wo
man gerade sowieso ein bisschen
emotional ist sondern einfach mal so
sagen die letzten challenge ist ein
bisschen einfacher aber gleichzeitig
kann sie auch ein bisschen schwieriger
sein als die vorherigen changes leuten
zu sagen dass man sie gerne hat also ich
glaube jeder von uns hat menschen gern
aber den leuten das zu sagen ist
manchmal gar nicht so leicht und glaube
es ist ganz gut dass ich mir jetzt
selbst dadurch so ein kleinen anhalter
geschaffen habe dass ich die dieses
video machte und einfach mal leuten sage
dass ich sie gerne habe also als erstes
werde ich mal meinen bruder sebastian
schreiben dessen gerhard weil wirklich
ich mag sebastian unglaublich gerne wie
möglich happy dass er mein bruder ist
bei ist immer so wie soll ich sagen es
ist ein bisschen komisch sage ich mal
dass man es im video zeigt was man
schreibt dass man sagt habe andererseits
ist es ändert ja nichts am wert also was
ich sage meine ich her bewegt also ich
hab meine mutter ist zum beispiel
einfach hält apple du bist ein super
großer bruder
ich hab dich lieb und ich freue mich
wenn wir uns wiedersehen solche
einfachen sachen ich mein zweites voll
freute sich jetzt drüber und irgendwie
mir geht's auch dabei gutes zu sagen
also so ich habe jetzt auch meine mama
einfach mal gesagt dass ich sie sehr
wertschätzen und meinem papa und ja man
könnte das ein mit beliebig vielen
leuten die man mag weiterführen aber ich
glaube es ist echt ne gute message und
gute gute letzte sache zum ersten mal
gemacht eigentlich verrückt dass ich das
noch nie gemacht habe so leute ich hab
selbst vergessen noch ein paar leute zu
nominieren und zwar nominiere ich luca
com kräfte als erstes dann revue du
musst auch machen
roth pilz juli m m und meinen eigenen
bruder escape den ich ja auch im video
erwähnt habe also ihr macht das
gefälligst weil ich glaube es ist echt
lustig und ihr zuschauer schreibt es den
leuten in die kommentare okay das war's
vom heutigen wie die ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen jetzt echt ne menge spaß
gemacht und ja bis zum nächsten mal